we have watched justice sheffield try
and work his way through what has been
essentially a season-long struggle and
it all comes down to that fastball
command and so the yanks have first and
second with one man out
and that'll bring up giancarlo
now here's the 0-1 swung on there goes
to left it is high that is far that is
gone off the railing of the second deck
it is a three-run home run it is a
stantonian home run
giancarlo
nosipo stopallo
now the yankees get a great start to
their road trip on a three-run
drive by giancarlo and the yankees take
a first inning three-nothing lead here
is gio urschella
here's the o2 and a swing and a miss by
your shell another slider for strike
three and there's two outs in the inning
there is strikeout
number one for justice sheffield so two
outs for the yankees who lead it three
nothing top of the first one on and
that'll bring up second baseman rugnet
odor
one on two outs
luke boyd lead at first base held on by
ty france now the set by sheffield the
kick and the 2-2 swing animus
got him with a fastball for strike three
and that will retire the side but the
yankees doing some damage three-run home
run off the bat of john carlos stanton
jameson taion uh you take a look at
where he is he comes in with a three and
four a five four three era ouch well
it's even more ouch on the road now here
is the first baseman ty france he's a
right hand hitter
and he hits a drive to right center
field caught by judge as he came in and
that'll do it for the first inning
for seattle no runs one hit one left at
the end of one three nothing yanks
miguel and duhar will lead things off
for new york here's a swing and a drive
straight away center field fraley going
back to the he track leaps up on the run
and he makes the catch crashes his
shoulder into the fence bounces off the
wall
holy smokes what a great running catch
by jake braley in straight away
centerfield robbing and duhar what a
play
yeah now here's right fielder aaron
judge here's the stretch and the 2-2
again swinging a ground ball up the
middle behind the bag diving stop is
dylan moore over to crawford at second
for the force there on le mayhew holy
smokes
what a play by dylan moore right back up
the middle moore diving to his right to
backhand it behind the bag
and here is sanchez who walked his first
time
once again it'll be a 3-2 to sanchez
and the pitch way high in fact it's a
wild pitch goes back to the screen
a run scores judge goes to third
on the walk and the wild pitch and the
yankees take a four nothing lead
but here's luke voight who's singled his
first time he's got the bases loaded two
out
top of the second yankees a four nothing
lead
judge at third
sanchez at second
stanton at first
two outs four nothing yanks top of the
second
and here's the o2
hit hard basic left field
two runs
will score
it's a two out two run single for luke
voight
and the yankees take a six-nothing lead
merchant strikeout on the first inning
here's the swing and a high fly ball
into the left center feeling shallow
racing in his freely jake is there and
he makes the catch and the top of the
second
is finally over yankees add three more
we go to the bottom of any number two
here's luis terence
former
yankee farm hand who
was a highly regarded prospect at a very
young age
here's the o2 to terence khan on a
missed high fastball two-way
this is jake bowers now
earlier this year the yankee saw bowers
with cleveland
that breaking balls cut on a missed 0-2
on bowers and they struck them out
it's a little tough it's a little tough
but they did strike them out
here is lemay who who is two for two
now here comes the 3-1 to dj
the pitch is swung on and lying to left
center field there's a base head
around third is rugi he is scoring
it's a base hit and an rbi for lemayo la
mayu is three for three in three innings
and the yankees take a seven nothing
lead and half person third one out for
judge
here's the two one to judge
swung on and line to left center field
there's another base hit one run scores
heading toward third
would be le mayhew
and he stops at third judge at second
with a double in the gap in left center
and the yankees take an eight nothing
lead two outs and two on for stanton
the o2
swinging a hard ground ball chopping its
way to france who has it well off the
back at first he flips to santiago who
tiptoes to the bag at first base for a
much needed out number three the yankees
strand two they get two we go to the
home third eight nothing new york dylan
moore is sitting at 183
he got power they all have power he has
seven homeless 26 rbis
now here's the o2
struck him out swinging fastball up at
93. seeger fly to center his first time
yankees have an eight-nothing lead
now here's the o2
struck him out swinging and i was a
change-up down and away and it was a
perfect pitch
now chew down
that'll bring up jake fraley the center
fielder
again the payoff
is strike three called at the knees on
the outside
number five strikeout for tyonne
three up three down at the end of four
innings to play eight nothing gangs
so bases loaded two out and here is
voight
now the 1-1
hit on the ground diving stop at third
and no play
search couldn't control it so it's a
base hit and an rbi
for voight his third hit of the game le
castro scores and the yankees now have a
nine nothing lead
francis twice flied out to judge in
right field
the pitch
swinging it's a fly ball out to shallow
left field and duhar racing and dives
and he can't make the catch he laid out
for it superman style crawford running
all the way crosses home and the
mariners get their first run of the game
comes with two outs and the bottom of
the six and that'll bring up dylan moore
the righty hitting second baseman with
two outs and no one on o2 is hit on the
ground to short archela backhand throws
in time what a play
he had a backhanded
on the edge of the outfield grass and
slung it and you know he slung it
perfectly
he always does he's so great he always
does yeah he does he does
here's oh door first and second nobody
out
oh here's the 3-1
swung on and hit in the air to deep
right it is high it is far it is gone
it's a three-run home run to deep right
right inside the pole by rugi odor
the second yankee three-run home run of
the night
jetta door
hey it's a three-run blast and the
yankees have a 12-1 loop luke voigt is
four for five on the night one two
point flicks that in the air to center
and he has a five hit
knight
luke voight with his first career
five hit game
well here is shed long a left-hand
hitter
and the pitch fest will cut on i missed
straight three ball game over yankees
win the
yankees when oh they needed this win